a lot of Disney films also they when the
sequel comes they expect the princess to
then like be an armor and have a sword
and fight and like oh that makes her
strong and and you know of course there
are princesses that it's necessary like
Mulan she is a fighter that's in her DNA
and and Aurora is a fighter but in a
different way I think there's a strength
in her femininity and softness and
there's nothing wrong with her
wanting to be a mother and and be
married and and you know my mom is a
always want to be a mom and I think
there's a beauty in that and that is
still strong so it's nice to represent
that you know kind of woman
preach preach sister oh man that was
common sense that everybody knew until
five minutes ago but now nobody knows it
so great great stuff